thank you I have a heart valve that's
leaking I've had four ablations and I am
currently in sinus rhythm
I've have IDI and a bladder that's
overactive and then my left ankle has
fallen with varicose veins from a knee
operation okay were you diagnosed with
atrial fibrillation yes okay yeah okay
that's usually why they give ablation
content to kill your heart muscle to try
and find the spot that's running amok
and giving you the fast part right and
the palpitations everything
what do you weigh sir I weigh 180 pounds
okay how tall are you a six foot one
okay okay any other issues diabetes high
blood pressure arthritis
no okay I'll touch otherwise I'm sorry
that blood pressure is very good
okay so otherwise other than this
bachelor stuff everything from varicose
veins a heart valve regurgitation
ablation for afib and that kind of stuff
you do have some II D and some
overactive bladder right yeah it gets
incontinence at pointa severe urges too
yeah
okay do you have a low back problem well
Bank just I would say minor if anything
well okay well you don't have to have a
lot of pain to have a low back problem
because what's happening with that
overactive bladder and the low back
problems Charmaine well it's even goes
into the afib it's all basically
mechanical and it's osteoporosis yeah
okay osteoporosis and also degenerative
disc disease have you shrunk any since
you were 20 years old yeah I'm having an
inch okay well there you go
you have degenerative disc disease that
means that the vertebrae are getting
closer together and char said smashing
the roots of the spinal nerves to
control your bladder to control your
heart rhythm and rate okay and of course
the doctors are just doing mechanical
things to chop stop your fat heart from
going fast and palpitating okay what are
going to do for this guy Charmaine
dietary wise first let's
look at his diet what's a good diet for
his issues and problems well he should
get on a gluten-free diet no fried foods
for sure and no burn animal fat no oils
of any kind and for his issues I would
get him on to healthy bone and joint
packs they're a test ultimate daily
classic vitamin d3 and MSM okay well
yeah you hit it all right on the message
and he said MSM and gluco gel right
because girl good job comes with a
healthy boner join packs right I throw
some selenium in also since you picked
that route okay I throw in some selenium
two bottles of slim he could take three
of those twice a day two healthy bone
and joint packs four months of full dose
earthing twice a day that's a 15 gluco
gel a day five at breakfast time at
lunch five at dinner to support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons discs between the
vertebrae why are we worried about discs
between the vertebrae Charmaine because
that's what's causing the afib and the
the bladder problem we have incontinence
you just walk along Tina's pants right
right and then yeah you got to give him
the raw materials to rebuild those discs
push the vertebrae apart okay and let's
see here and also and you said the
ultimate daily classic tablets right yep
for the heart valve issues and that kind
of stuff which may or may not be true
but let's give them the healthy or the
ultimate daily classic tablets and three
of those twice a day two bottles a month
they're designed to support and promote
healthy blood pressure but also healthy
blood flow through the coronary arteries
in the brain arteries and the kidney
arteries are important here and then
give us a call every two weeks in
Michigan it's gonna take you 3 to 5 days
to get the product start your diet
immediately a chart said get rid of the
bad stuff fried foods processed meats
oils and glutens and and then as soon as
two weeks happy to start your supplement
program call us in two weeks in four
weeks and six we will walk you through
this Thomas we deal with this literally
thousands of times a month around the
world people respond exactly correctly
because guess what the body wants to
heal itself it just requires these
nutrients